[Laughter]
hmm
[Music]
you
if you ain't start in the morning like
that you split the [ __ ] Sunday July
3rd it's a whole new [ __ ] month and
all the Lucetta rules [ __ ] uncle
Joey here on the Lord's they smoke and
pray and get on me dog you gotta stay on
top of this [ __ ] I had my little humming
no smoothie couple numbers I'm ready for
you Jitsu with 12 church 7:30 a.m.
you know me though he's gonna walk on
ice you might as well dead [ __ ] 4th
of July weekend I hope you get your [ __ ]
together hope you spending time with
your families or hope you're [ __ ]
having a good time hope you got invited
to a [ __ ] barbecue you know all these
things I'm hoping for you good for more
people me I'm gonna get to the middle
schwarmann I'm gonna meet some people
with on a podcast and I got a spot at
the store tonight you know me bill it
never [ __ ] inch you people think I'm
over here and I was [ __ ] down here and
I had with nobody hangout solo and about
me the baby the cat's my refund
and that's it just trying to get the day
started right
I'm happy you're here I'm happy we'll
get my [ __ ] little buzz together then
you gonna do what the [ __ ] you gotta do
baby hold on the shore maybe you gonna
[ __ ] I don't know the Sabbath day I
don't [ __ ] know who gives a
Frenchman's flop that's what we say here
right [ __ ] now oh yeah that's it
some tremendous people Disneyland gonna
stamp me Disneyworld Disneyland having a
don't even know what it's [ __ ] ball
from sunset I will tell you one thing it
gets you [ __ ] up with my eyeball Jack
straight up gangster wheat in the
morning so this is what you wanted you
see the devil
this [ __ ] will make the
introduction oh [ __ ]
just like that flavor bringing it to you
you know 7:24 if you're not gonna smoke
with the big boys get on for going out
with the other [ __ ] yet don't do
whatever the [ __ ] you gotta do but here
we go deep into the murky waters of the
under cuz I love you too much hey I'm
with you you you wouldn't May there with
us and that's it
I did my CBD oil I'm ready though people
this is a cold glass of water start the
morning to get the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
metabolism bone and try and people
that's all you could do is just try if
you sit there like a [ __ ] month
that's one thing but if you try oh yeah
tell or do more saving
have I told you I love marijuana even
Muslim before what did you lie the
fireworks
they make me all [ __ ] up insane but I
love you [ __ ] really don't think
a little [ __ ] don't break us this
[ __ ] weed ran through me
and that's it not with doing a dog
straight 24 it's a beautiful day to be
alive it's a whole new week to do your
[ __ ] goals do your push-ups and
that's it you got this all [ __ ]
couple you need me for yeah I'm Sam I'm
just a [ __ ] painting yes
I said [ __ ] I gotta go to the
bathroom I checked with your
[ __ ] later on location was
smoking dope all day after this I gotta
go to brainy
I'm picking up a [ __ ] big shipment
I'm Becca picking up a big shipment
Hannibal's we're going deep this week I
get surgery on the 10th I gotta take it
to another loop you understand me I love
you [ __ ]
stay black have a good day I love you
Muslims without you I got nothing